[Music]
okay mr. top of the leaderboard did you
surprise yourself I mean you're
literally at the top of the leaderboard
is that's actually still insane to me
even though it's been a few days but
like I mean I went into this with zero
expectation I didn't want to embarrass
myself but like I don't know like I've
never danced I'm afraid to dance in
front of people something this is kind
of really out of my element but I've
I've grown to love dancing so much and
like was waiting in my partner like
having so much fun it was like I loved
it so I'm glad it's kind of showing and
hopefully people will keep voting so I
can keep going because I don't want to
stop anytime soon because I really I
really do love it the best song choices
though you're seeing you dancing too in
sync how does that bending fit into
guilty pleasure
well my guilty pleasure is that I'm a
big fan of boy bands you know normally I
wanted to hit that but you know what I'm
already wearing sequins and dancing in
front of millions people I can go ahead
and throw out there the fact that I like
boy bands so that's gonna in sync it's
gonna be me which I love this song we do
do a little breakdown a little boy band
thing in there but uh most of its samba
so it's you know the boy band things a
little more in my element than the samba
but my hips just don't move
serious question how does Nick Lachey
feel that you're dancing too insane oh I
I went up to the other day and I said
you know I'm doing you know my guilty
pleasures boy bands so like I need I
need some tips and you know most of it
was just like the points and the you
know the nods and the yeses you know so
I got that down I just got a you know
figure out the rest
[Music]
you